[Music]
in spicy drama news whoo you know
Mexicans are involved submitted by I
love JK the former nanny of Mel B aka
Scary Spice
you know from Spice Girls yeah for libel
in breach of privacy what's liable - oh
that's like I'm questioning it
who is she suing yeah what senior she
said people impeach my privacy all the
time he's suing Scary Spice look like
the shoes she's the black girl I was to
defame someone watching a label so
defamation oh I don't want to BD famoust
yeah so the nanny's name is Lorraine
she's 26 years old
oh worked with Mel B aka Scary Spice
since 2009 when she was 18
oh that's a long job yeah and so
apparently Lorraine is being accused of
getting pregnant by Stephen that young
pussy's harder was this well so Mel B is
making a lot of claims so he'll be
saying that Mel B was forced into
threesomes with the nanny by her husband
that's more use the celebrity is forced
into the threesome by the hired help
oh they're divorced now right yes so you
know this I I remember the story of them
getting divorced because of a babysitter
yeah so that's a secret Spice Girls I
know to become
no don't be ashamed own it own your
spice girl oh there we go it's our time
that's why it was our time but I never
listen to them you're just saying their
song it's catchy
it's catchy it's our time but like it's
not like I bought their CD and all that
like it's like did you watch if you
listen to like kiss FM or the pop
stations it's always on you just turn on
MTV in it's on it's on TRL
yes so um so is that why you guys spider
rap no that's the same song yeah yeah oh
is it that's the same song I love how
you corrected me too
[Laughter]
do you know the name of that song tell
me what you want what you want no I
don't want to be no moving on no so
anyways yeah Mel B and her husband got
divorced in March after a 10-year
marriage and they have three kids
together so that's why I'm learning was
her nanny and so Mel is just claiming
that her husband had been hitting her
for all these years that she's been
hiding the abuse and that apparently
like the last straw was when Lauren got
pregnant and Stephen wanted her to keep
the baby but so it's true so she got
pregnant by Stephen that's what Mel B's
claiming oh so there's like all these
different sites to this whole story cuz
it's like Mel B side and then Stephen
side and then learning who's the husband
Stephen Stephen Bellefonte I mean was he
like somebody yeah he's a film director
oh I wonder what kind of films he made
let me go go Stephen Belafonte cuz you
know entertainment people tend to marry
the entertainment people or something
like that and then when a producer
always a producer
who's there about him if he's also like
a girl beater on the side what he pities
makes me wonder produced the movies a
bad lieutenant port of call New Orleans
mo P straight from the projects so stuff
that doesn't matter
hurt her career like outshine all like
he's in her shadow because she's still
relevant she should have got with
somebody there's got talent or the other
one one of those which one do you dance
either make a start on or making idle no
no it's America's Got to you think you
can dance do you think you can dance no
it's America's Got Talent
yeah she's a judge right you know she's
awesome on that show yeah The X Factor
oh [ __ ] this X Factor yeah that is your
director because it had the talent shows
that was still America though we're all
wrong no it's alright I think they have
X's but this one is the x-factor I see
it's a good singing thing oh really oh
[ __ ]
I was completely hob did you think it
was the talent show yeah Colin shallow
to research that I'm both I don't know
who [ __ ] cares but the point is that
there's always drama that's the point
saying so all this drama was started
basically because she was like kind of
the whistleblower right Mel B he's the
one that like kind of started putting
everything out there she's had enough
she's like I'm gonna tell the public
they need to know I don't even know why
they have to tell the public yeah and
then so the husband was interviewed by
TMZ or like you know he was being Marty
cuz you think he's going in his car and
TMZ was like hey do you have any
comments based off would melt be saying
and Stephen was just like you know what
she's the mother of my children all I
gotta say is that this is like I'm just
worried about my children because
they're great kids and then being
exposed to all this I don't know how
it's gonna affect them so he didn't
really I mean he did like sort of deny
the claims but that's mainly what he had
to say from what I saw so anyway this is
Mel B this is her husband actually
really ex-husband and then this is the
babysitter yeah
Lorraine you know Laker why would he
leave Scary Spice for that he didn't
leave her so apparently he got Bo what
do you think is gonna happen though you
know he and he had a threesome
yeah so Melfi was saying that she was
forced into these threesomes but then
Lorraine is saying like no we were it
was all consensual and they held reasons
for real yeah and then I apparently melt
be with a cameraman for a lot of it and
that she Loreen is saying that she would
never see would enough sex with Steven
unless she was instructed to by Mel P
and that Mel B would be there and she
would be filming them having sex so this
is all coming from her so that's what
she's saying we're the videos that I
needed no and then Mel B's lawyers are
saying that Stephen has those tapes and
that he's claiming to ruin her career by
releasing them so I think it would just
make her career bigger this is a setup
yeah so then here's a Lorraine Stephen
and then the kids two kids they actually
look good together are they even scary
spicy's kids are they her kids
they're scary explain again we need some
DNA testing I'm pretty sure she knows if
they're her kids did she she probably
came around to afterwards right maybe
he's the one that might not be sure but
I'm pretty sure she wouldn't have yeah
thank you the guy he dragged a little
walk I'm so sorry
yeah but anyway so here's some photos of
when they were together and then she has
like a bandage on her cheek kind of
stroller is that does she say that he
beat her so she is that Mel B is now
saying that that was a evidence of his
abuse but that she in that time she hit
it saying that like she was running in
seven-inch heels and that now she's
wearing Prague on her face and so she's
just like trying to brush it off like it
was something else but now is she's
saying I was hiding it that was actual
abuse and then this thing - yeah what is
that a STD she said yeah she said
dealing with a really bad eye infection
blah blah and so now that's a check he
gave her that's what she posted but then
now she's saying that that was also
evidence of the abuse I doesn't look
like abused of his laureen's to do on
her face that looks like a skin disease
that's a green worm yeah this is like
marks when she is on the show like fans
had pointed out that she had like
bruises he [ __ ] grabbed about the
armpits and sugar yeah so what is
lorraine suing her for like the
defamation so Loreen is saying that so
milky is dragging her in this whole
messy divorce and Lorena's saying like
hold on like this was all consensual and
like you were the one telling us to do
this and and then as she was claiming
Loreen got pregnant in a one-night stand
from someone else but then that Mel B's
twisting it saying that no she got
pregnant but my husband and then my
husband used my money to pay for her boy
she let a stranger just bust in her from
a one-night stand
she's my day to God she does all
abortion so much of this personal
information that's so sad now the real
question is how come those guys out
there if he really is being the [ __ ] out
of this Mel B and he's an [ __ ] how
come he still has to how come he still
gets to have four kids and three sons
and all the perks but he's a [ __ ]
dick face
it doesn't make no sense to my idea of
Social Services took the kids I'm very
nice I don't beat any girls but I don't
have ten kids that love me I don't I
don't you know like well Mel B gets to
[ __ ] the babysitter to and get her
pregnant not that that's what I want but
I'm just saying I don't want to [ __ ]
that babysitter yeah I can't even afford
like a young babysitter like that my
nanny would look like a 60 year old you
would be mrs. Dunphy
yeah no but yeah so Loreen is just
saying that her reputation got like
damaged love she from nobody knew who
the [ __ ] you were until you [ __ ] got
yourself involved in this now I know you
now now I know you're the nanny that
that sucks dick that image that she's a
bag having money extorting homewrecker
and also Mel B's fans were attacking her
online and so she was just saying like
I'm getting all this [ __ ] it wasn't
even like I don't deserve it
poor girl yeah King so hey excuse me I
didn't get [ __ ] pregnant by him I got
it out of one nightstand thank you very
much oh that should that you're not a
[ __ ] anymore I'm sorry I'm so sorry I
just mislabeled you yeah currently a
judge granted Mel B a restraining order
against Loraine and her husband so it's
like well maybe the judge has there's
evidence eeeh
proof right leave her alone she needs to
be on X Factor she has work to do to
find all the talent and of this world
there's a lot of talent that is just
ready to be shown discovered discovered
I mean I could do the show without her
to know hey you guys want to stock any
of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]